- Watch out, watch out, watch out,
watch out, watch out, watch out,
watch out, watch out,
Chicken Watch 2K16!
(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] We're doing it.
- [Both] Chicken Watch 2K16!
- You're outta wiper fluid, bro.
- I know, I've been outta
wiper fluid for ages.
- What if a bunch of
dirt gets on the front?
- It's a whole new game.
We're gonna go find
the best fried chicken.
- From any grocery store.
- In Los Angeles.
- We're trying to represent all
the chains of America today.
- That's right.
- Let's get to the nitty gritty.
What makes good fried chicken good?
- [Both] Rubric.
- Beauty.
- Crispiness is the number one factor.
- It needs to be moist.
- Moist.
We've got sexy nod, we've got wow factor.
I'm a drumstick man myself.
- I'm a breast boy.
- You're a breast boy?
You wanna be our wing man?
- I can be the wing man.
- Alright, Kevin's our wing man.
Hopefully we'll assemble
a team of thigh guys
by the end of the day.
- I think we should go to Food4Less first.
- This Food4Less feels like you're
preparing for an earthquake.
- [Keith] You look good.
- Oh thanks.
- [Keith] Yeah.
- [Both] Chicken Watch 2K16!
- [Chris] One breast, one
thigh, one leg, one wing.
- [Keith] Food4Less, how'd you know?
- So you think it's just
a regular box, right?
Oh no, it turns into a handle!
- I can't handle it.
- [Both] Chicky, oooh.
- I say we do beauty right off the bat.
- It does look terrible.
- Mmm, crispiness,
and we're gonna say eh, ya meh.
Moisture.
- Solid moist.
- We need to cover for seasoning.
- This is salty as fuck.
Well how did you rate your drumstick?
- I think I can do a lot better.
- There's better chicken
titties out there.
- Wing man!
- Thumbs up, thumbs down?
- Like one of these.
- Okay, okay.
No thigh guys present so
the thigh will go with us.
There's a police officer over there.
- I say no wow factor.
- No sexy nod.
- Ok we'll close it up.
- We will not film anymore on the
- [Both] Chicken Watch 2K16!
- Now we're going to Von's Hollywood.
- Von's Hollywood.
♫ Yeah, fried chicken is my favorite food
♫ It takes so damn good
♫ I put it into my throat, you see
♫ Everybody wishes they could just be me
♫ But they can't cause I'm the only Keith
♫ You know what fuels me as I do my drive
♫ You know what fuels
me, what keeps me alive
♫ You know what fuels me
till the day that I die
♫ It's chicken motherfucker
♫ And the chicken, it's fried
♫ It's Chicken Watch 2K16
♫ It's Chicken Watch 2K16 ♫
(coughs)
- You okay?
- Yeah.
- [Both] Oooh!
- [Keith] They're just putting it out.
That's amazing.
- [Chris] Well you've just
put that fried chicken
out there, this is fresh stuff!
- Chicken Watch 2K16.
- [Keith] Chicken Watch 2K16.
(plastic squeaking)
Ooh, did you hear that?
- Um, I'm gonna say that
this beauty is killin' it.
- It's pretty golden ble-beautiful.
The crunch is--
- I thought it was going to
be there more than it was.
You guys want some?
Okay.
- We'd prefer you be in the video.
- I mean we'd prefer
but you don't have to.
- We can blur out your face
and destroy your voice.
- Moisture?
- Would you say it has a wow factor or no?
Our first honorary thigh guy.
You picked that thing off dry.
- I know.
- I'll tell ya that I
don't think it's the best.
Wing man get in here.
- Wing man?
- Not even like kinda, like way up.
- Can you just say Chicken
Watch 2K16 with us?
Oh come on!
It's just like a tag.
Why not?
- We made a friend, although
she ditched us immediately
but we're gonna keep
on continuing on the--
- [Both] Chicken Watch 2K16!
♫ It's a guy over there
and he looks like a thigh
♫ It's a girl over there,
she's a drumstick guy
♫ She's playing the drums
with a bunch of drumsticks
♫ And a bunch of fuckin' breasts
♫ With a bunch of fuckin' dicks
♫ I tell you what, if I had 30 dicks
♫ I'd sell 29 and buy some fried chicks ♫
(laughing)
- Hit us with a chicken fact, Kevin.
- Alright well...
The chicken is the closest living relative
to the great tyrannosaurus rex.
- What?
- How far the T-Rex has fallen.
- Alright, we're about
to go into Whole Foods.
Getting ready for people to be really hot
or hippies.
Hmm, smells good.
Chicken Watch 2K16
- [Keith] We're doing a video right now,
you wanna come with us to do it?
- [Voiceover] Yeah sure.
- [Keith] Let's go.
- There it is.
Beauty is definitely obviously.
- Do you wanna be our wing lady?
- Sure.
- Sorry Kevin.
- No, it's not crunch.
- Mine's dry.
- The least seasoned.
- The leg was mediocre.
- This breast is disappointing.
- Neither a good experience
nor a negative experience.
- About a medium.
- Okay.
- Definitely no wow factor for me.
- No sexy nod.
- Whole Foods, you're
great for healthy food.
For unhealthy food, not quite a win.
- [All] Chicken Watch 2K16!
- Chicken Watch 2K16.
- [Keith] Nice!
♫ I can drive with my thighs
♫ 'Cause I'm a real thigh guy
- Hit us with a chicken fact, Kev.
- Alright so, chickens can distinguish
between more than 100 different faces,
so they'll always remember you.
- Alright, we're at Gelson's.
- [All] Chicken Watch 2K16!
- Oh, I feel terrible.
- Alright.
- Is it beautiful, we
didn't even judge it.
(mumbling)
It's moist enough but
it's like the most bland.
You have any seasoning?
- I have good crunch.
- I didn't ask you that.
- How you feelin'?
- Not great.
- In general, or because of the chicken?
- The chicken.
How would you rate your leg?
- Feels high class.
- Gimme the camera, you try the wing.
- Well, it's crunchy, it's moist.
- [Keith] Can you please
keep it to the thumb rating,
Kevin, please?
- Oh, I'm sorry.
Upper thumb.
- No wow factor.
- [Keith] No sex nod.
- I feel like you're high
on chicken right now, Keith.
- [Keith] Kevin!
My phone's dead.
- Well plug it in.
- It won't, it won't, it won't.
♫ Yo, gimme some chicken,
I don't mean to beg
♫ Which came first, the
chicken or the egg ♫
- Hit us with a chicken fact, Kevin.
- Did you know that chickens
can taste sweetness?
- Damn.
Chickens are pretty fuckin' versatile.
- Then you should know how
sweet that rap was, chicken.
- I said can't by the way.
- Oh can't?
- They can't taste it.
- They can't taste sweetness, oh okay.
(laughing)
Alber, the tson's behind the tree.
- So much.
Chicken Watch 2K16.
- Chicken Watch 2K16.
That's my breast baby!
Alright should we--
- That love at first sight type feeling.
That's what I'm fucking talking about.
There's seasoning there, there was crunch,
and there was also moisture.
- It's so balanced.
My breast, it's big like a
D, but it's a score of an A.
- The skin--
- There's a long strand of
hair coming off that somehow,
where'd that come from?
- Fuck around, I'm gonna
be a thigh guy too.
- You're gonna be a thigh guy?
- Oh 180!
All the way up.
- That's like 1,000 degrees.
- I'm so happy.
This gets my wow factor,
it gets my sexy nod.
I think a song might just be the right way
to end the Chicken
- [All] Watch 2K16!
- Go!
♫ Alright my ladies, you
know how this one goes
♫ If you a chicken watcher in the crowd
♫ You dance with us, yeah,
and it goes like this
♫ Watch out, watch out, watch out
♫ Watch out, watch out, Chicken Watch 2K16
♫ Wing wing wing and a wing wing wang
♫ Now where my breast dudes
and where my breast boys
♫ And where my breast dudes
♫ And thigh guys, thigh
guys, thigh guys, hi guys
♫ Thigh guys, thigh
♫ Watch out, watch out, watch out
♫ Watch out, watch out, Chicken Watch 2K16
♫ Wing wing wing and a wing wing wang
- Thanks for joining us
on another taste adventure
with the Flavor Buds.
- That's right we'll see you next time on
- [Both] Chicken Watch 2K16, wooh!
(upbeat music)